im pflicht werden sie sich unter einer
impfpflicht für sie kommt ja schon
früher vor der allgemeinen pflicht sie
müssen sich schon impfen lassen weil sie
eben in diesem pflegebereich drin sind
beruflich werden sie sich dann impfen
lassen oder sind sie was hat der müller
gerade gesagt oder herr kessler weiter
bockig oder stur ist er hat er kissler
das land bleiben so störrisch
ich bin weiter stören weil ich nicht
sehe dass diese impfung den weg bringt
dir der erwünscht ist
warum wer liegt denn auf den anderen
neuen
intensivbetten in der intensivstation
verlegt denn dort das sind doch
über auch patienten die durch die kurven
impfung erkrankt sind und mir geht es
doch nicht um mich mit geht es um viele
andere die da draußen einfach angst
haben vor der impfungen und das sich
nicht als
versuchsobjekt daten zur verfügung
stellen wollen es gibt doch ich habe es
doch anfangs schon berichtet von den
nebenwirkungen und also ich habe angst
davor dass die die betten in den
krankenhäusern immer mehr damit gefüllt
werden noch dazu kommt jetzt die
impfpflicht wo wir das pflegepersonal
aus dem krankenhaus und verabschieden
weil es gibt mehr vielmehr die so denken
und sich nicht zwingen lassen
sagt wenn die impfpflicht kommt lassen
wir uns dann freiwillig im darüber
diskutieren
das ist ein wichtiger punkt der das
tatsächlich natürlich eine gewisse
bewegung gibt die da und sagen na dann
können wir ja nicht mehr zur arbeit
kommen wir wollen aber vor allen dingen
natürlich gleich noch mal hinterfragen
inwiefern diese impfpflicht sinnvoll
sein kann in einer zeit in der sich das
virus erheblich verändert hat in der
nicht klar ist dass eine impfung erst
zweite impfung zumindest deutlich vor
omikron vor dieser neuen variante eben
schützen